gonflé le moral de ses troupes c'est
dans cette optique que le président
ukrainien s'est rendu sur la ligne de
front face aux séparatistes pro russes
dans la région de donetsk à un moment où
les relations ne cesse de se dégrader
avec moscou
la russie est accusé par kiev et ses
alliés d'avoir massé des troupes et des
blindés à sa frontière avec l'ukraine et
ce en vue d'une possible attaque le
kremlin dément mais exige que kiev ne
rejoignent pas l'otan de leur côté les
états unis ont prévenu si les russes
tentent d'envahir leurs voisins ils
feront l'objet de sanction financière
inédite washington qui se dit prêt à
stationner plus de militaires en europe
de l'est n'envisage toutefois pas pour
le moment de riposte militaire directe
en cas d' attaque
à
ces menaces tombe seulement quelques
heures avant un entretien
visioconférence entre les présidents
byden et poutine
leader mondial des métiers disparus
après un entretien ce lundi soir les
dirigeants américain français italiens
britanniques et allemands se sont dits
déterminés à ce que la souveraineté de
l'ukraine soit respectée